you're welcome a new video 15-minute
game playing against judge meek from
this is Sweden right Sweden
yeah it's very nice here those flecks
you know the more after a while I still
have my issues with some of the
Scandinavian flags though all right so
we got a Sicilian I'm going to play the
count variation with a six I recently
had to brief look at this this line okay
he's gone Nazi three the main Rufus
Bishop to d3 here and after this I
looked at some interesting line 93 is of
course a fine a fine move but that's not
the one I I looked at so how to continue
yeah but can can play this kind of
flexible Queen c7 Knight f6 set up and
decide later how to place the pieces
there's also b5 as a good alternative
yeah here black can play various moves
you can go also I think be 596 also d6
transposing into some kind of skimming
and setup but the bishop is on d3 that's
an important difference to other lines
and the sicilian arising from the
skinning and not the night off
their Bishop d3 is very rarely possible
so very often the bishop on d3 is some
slight improvement for white compared to
those lines but there are also downsides
like this year with Bishop c5 I'm
attacking the knight and yeah provoking
this retreat so on I go back of course
to e7 cannot allow him to take the
bishop so you might ask okay what is the
point of this maneuver black plays 2
moves to get the bishop to 7 and in the
meantime White has moved tonight
yeah the night on b3 is simply worse
compared to on prefer to deform
it's very often it is a typical maneuver
and the Sicilian to attack the knight on
d4 with the bishop are very often with
the Queen from b6 then the knight
retreats to b3 and then the Queen drops
back to c7 or the bishop drops back and
all in all this is considered to be a a
good trade-off for black okay I think
the normal way to play this year as the
so called third rank setup like F for
Queen to f3 and Bishop to e3 so our
pieces here on the 3rd rank this is a
normal way to to play this and black
will set up the typical um yes giving a
no Hedgehog type
I've set up probably more like a hat
shop than is given in and with Knight to
d7 & b6 this kind of setup an important
point of the night going to going to be
three years that if I play e5 at some
moment with the knight on d4 very often
that f5 is a good answer and now the
night is on b3 away from all this so I
have the chance to play
65 at some moment where the Snider
doesn't arrest me
yeah if I if the question is it's a five
position of threat here I'm not sure
a four a five is very often on an issue
the question is what can I do I can but
I could play b6 b6 the only issue with
more flag be sixes the reply be five the
very direct if five but I'm not sure
that I really want to allow him to to
play em to play a five sometimes but
it's possible and not such a big deal
I'd like to prevent that reading I hope
that on e5 exactly I can play Knight to
d7
if I take take 97 he's got Queen f3 and
this sum is very embarrassing
so probably I need to go here and hope
them there's nothing particularly wrong
with this it looks a bit shaky
yeah he's gaining on quite some time
here hmm now I cannot really allow him
to take besides if I Castle for example
he takes on d6 and takes on h7 and I'm
just material down so I probably need to
move the bishop again and after Bishop
d7 for instance he he might play a five
yeah this looks very dangerous my Lycan
development really has some quite
yeah
it doesn't inspire much confidence but
the thing is if if he doesn't have some
direct knockout then then I'm perfectly
all right
I just need one or two moves to to
complete my set up and then it's
questionable if those F four moves are
good and if his King is really good very
often this this F pawn moves mean that
White's King is only sheltered by H 2
and G 2 and in the long run often blacks
King with a complete pawn shield on the
King side is the most secure one so he
really needs to get going now quickly
otherwise I think I'm pretty okay at
least it shouldn't be M shouldn't be
terrible
it seems dangerous though my I admitted
yeah so yeah f55 was one of those very
direct tries how to continue here
yeah the simplest time would be just
just to take it but I'm not sure that
Europe takes that five but what is the
exact threat
yeah maybe Bishop f4 what if I take he
made my play Bishop f4 anyway maybe okay
I don't want to spend ages here the
alternatives didn't look so great anyway
Knight c3 okay I didn't consider this at
all I hope this doesn't mean I
overlooked something important here
okay ninety-five I understand but is it
is it such a big issue
I don't be should be Sam okay let's
cavity five I mean ninety five is a
threat cannot allow him to to go there
if you please Bishop takes a five now I
think I can maybe just play Knight f6
back controlling e4 and e5 and then
maybe just cancel yeah thing is if I'm
not if this position it's not them we
should reform let's think about that
let's think for a moment IAM if i'm not
worse immediately then this is really a
good position what i need to do i need
to preserve this p7 bishop of course
it's a very strong piece and I'd like to
play Bishop d6 attacking his age to pawn
but I cannot cannot do that at the
moment Bishop d6 looks um rather rather
problematic I'd like to play Knight f6
but then he's got Bishop f4 and this is
really a very annoying move to face
I can play queen c6 but I'm not sure
that that I want dad it's probably not
not terrible but it's not the setup I
intended to tend to play yeah maybe
maybe I need to do that Bishop d6
Bishop d6 is maybe an option but after
Queen check on e2 I need to move the
King it's also not exactly what I wanted
to do okay let's play this move I could
have played this much quicker of course
yeah now probably Bishop that form and
then my attention was queen c6 there's
not much else
hmm yeah yeah Bishop affords the very
the very obvious choice now I'm doubt
that there should be something
substantially better
this is before I must play Quincy six I
mean he cannot play anywhere else I need
this made threat to gain gain a move we
should have for Quincy six maybe Queenie
two and then we have maybe short Castle
he cannot take it seven because of made
on g2 very shaky position white can play
94 but then I've got Bishop c5 huh this
way yeah okay maybe he intends to play
94 next move but I must I must get out
of this year no doubt and this is also a
potential pain Bishop c5
yeah unless them there's some some very
direct drawback to this I actually like
my position but it can can be a problem
all the time some some concrete player
services as possible as I'm not very
well developed I've got like two moves
are ninety seven ninety five then black
is instantly yeah better even Wow there
what's the idea
I mean it works directly into ninety
seventy five
this is where I'm wondering
rook t8 I can also play up the end
maybe then Queen to h3 or something
now come on I need to let's let's
connect rooks and complete the
development yes but so there's some
threat even I mean not at the moment
right I cannot see five um we will play
Knight to g4 probably
yeah I don't have a good scrap or the
care for the Queen amazingly
hmm this is very annoying 94 maybe maybe
I must prepare must prepare or this like
Rock dat look at the end look at the end
and then 95 he cannot play 94
if he goes 94 now I can play Quincy for
attacking the snide and intending Bishop
c5 I don't really see am a concrete
threat I mean I can of course may be
overlooked all wide and a lot of whites
ideas but it still seems quite okay to
me
yeah what what could one do and he can't
play em try something like Bishop g5
attacking trying to get something on age
7 but don't really see how this leads to
something I'm tangible all right okay
let's let's get this night into into
play if the exchanges Bishop takes c5
then black shirt should be really fine
he's got Bishop III to break the pin but
rupee a dent takes Queen takes and I
just just controlling the center I'm not
so sure what this directly going for h7
okay
this intense 94 this is a good move and
I move that I shouldn't have missed
really hmm yeah this is bad
he's got 94 now very very problematic
might be three takes I have six very
very very awful
so g6 Wow
she six looks like a complete disaster
this was bad
there should be five very really good
move probably
so h 6e m h 694
yeah I don't even have a moves after 94
where do I move the Queen
yeah
yeah maybe maybe g6 I don't see a move
taken if you place 94 I can take it and
take f5 but this looks like like a
disaster I didn't see some some other
moves to be honest it's aged 694 what
can I do
I can sex the exchange but this is
clearly not sufficient
yeah I thought takes on d4 takes on f5
maybe it is this just maybe it just not
working but didn't didn't see anything
else
yeah this pinion on the long diagonal is
of course are in terrible
yeah just just rook checks them and this
is this cannot be this is probably not
not 94 maybe I can plain rook takes a
five Knight to e4 Knight takes Knight
takes and I've got Queen g6 as a
possible defense yeah I'm probably it
has got some some very simple drawback
but I don't I don't see it at the moment
maybe even this annoyed the F night and
Queen to g6 iscope maybe look at four
this night doesn't threaten anything
okay so queen g4 I have kept Queen g6 so
yeah well this cannot work it would be
really a miracle as if this shouldn't be
a frost check made on or some other
winner and I don't see I don't see it at
the moment yeah this is probably
probably enough yeah but but but but
wait wait wait
not not so quick it's probably winning
but
hmm
do I need to play a Bishop to g8 this
would be a really really ugly Bishop g5
he can just take because of lag bish 97
check yeah whatever I just lost anyway
go to the aid
when I don't see the loss at the moment
but really can't believe it that
shouldn't be winning maybe before
something I'm just
Luke age five now maybe Queen z6r look
f4 look afford reform so very simple but
probably effective
yeah at least them it seems that he
hasn't found a complete kill um as well
this is really really nice jinx yes at
the end at the end he dnt takes on only
of six with the rookie oh this is the
problem
yeah well you threatened squeegee for
him anyway but oh wait wait wait wait 24
I've got 25 if I go 2525 24 25 okay
rupees six is not winning okay yeah this
is like walking on Titan on some odd is
called a tightrope
yeah and now Queen g5 hoping that this
somehow maybe you can just take and take
b6m
maybe here at active for it takes p7 I
can take the form at least I'm not
melted I was 100% sure I get take it
checkmate it and the game is still
running at least okay I must move the
bishop somewhere you should before these
got h4 so somewhere else
yeah how to get counterplay the only
chance is to to use Knights and Bishop
against the King this is the only only
way to to go about that he's got so many
pawns no no other chance okay I'm taking
a taking of seven
trying to get the bishop to g6 and - or
maybe night at 5 a.m. could also be
could also be an option later 5
yeah at least these pieces look active
I'm not sure what they're doing but it's
a little bit menacing maybe I can get in
rook da de it takes okay I think he's
lost the thread of bit here my pieces
look active now I've got possible Luke
g6 coming loop g6 g3 and I can I can
even sack here can do that but you can
take on f5 and rook e8 this is this
problem okay let's just take it here and
go here how does it protect the Jeep or
no and this is unbelievable I'm still in
this game okay - yeah
check
time warning
let's just check made in one move with
20 seconds of the clock after this
defense no I forgot about the checkmate
threat and I will probably very
disappointed to see that that that yeah
I'm simply better I believe I'm not
better this is very surprising why am I
not better here in this position I mean
it seemed from from material point of
view but here rook e8 and rook e8 what
okay okay this is clear this must be
okay for black I mean no no question and
this is a draw with rook c1 when drew
come at Roxy tune yeah okay didn't I
didn't have have time anymore to to look
at this yeah this is better for white
already yeah I don't get him eat him
after this defense
I really really let me into this game
again I mean I had all pieces on the
back rank and now look at this f5 before
it's not so bad and the computer
valuations plus two wherever this is not
really applicable to a game of humans
yeah I was absolutely sure to to get
something here the computer gives f5
with an advantage to black yeah not sure
how serious that is but it's
understandable
I mean f5 I keep all those pieces and go
up C to next month and then defend your
kingside please the bad thing was also
if you look at this here here I intended
this movie on but it doesn't work
because a rook takes a five is very
lucky for white otherwise black would
simply be a bit better here cannot
defend if he goes g3 I could take if it
weren't for he can he can he can even
capture it's no maid okay I see yeah
I've got some play but it's not enough
really
yeah well probably I was I was made at
some point oh yeah I was really
surprised that I didn't I didn't get
meted here the computer wants to play
Queen d7 and claims equality yeah okay
this is the computer yeah this this
Bishop e5 move was very strong here the
computer valuation is about equal but we
should be fine I didn't really didn't
really appreciate of course I knew that
g6 looks very shaky but I didn't see
something else yeah your computer just
wants to know Queen e8 but with the bad
position yeah okay this was my intention
of this sleep and it's clear that this
is very very dangerous
and it's lost yeah it's lost
hmm yeah of course I had lost lots of
time here in the opening 23h fries was
suppose weird but here here I thought
about this is maybe strong I am the
computer also gives that but I didn't
want to move all those pieces again walk
the ATM
yes I can yeah I actually saw that but
as much I didn't want to move all pieces
again here Queen 2 H 3 s the idea the
office idea and then Bishop c8 I saw
that this is some pretty decent defense
against this age 7 not pressure but I
didn't want to undeveloped it this
Bishop is not bad on b7 yeah Bishop III
maybe something like that I don't know I
can then next move take and I think I'm
pretty solid it's not not so much
computers on 0.3 so just minimal minimal
advantage for want yeah a very
interesting game I think would have been
nice to some more save it at the end but
I fear I failed to deserve to this may
turn at the end on very complicated game
and very well played by in my opponent
yeah thanks for watching